hey good morning from the free state of
florida everybody i wanted to give a
quick update and then i wanted to talk
about martin luther king jr for just a
moment uh our plan was to be back in
studio today there was one more slight
delay uh with the house we are
officially in tomorrow
and we'll have internet wednesday
morning so what we're gonna do
is tomorrow night tuesday we will do a
test show we're gonna try to rig
together some crazy internet just to do
a test show and we're going to set up
the studio and then wednesday at 11 a.m
eastern the reuben report returns
officially i really thank you guys for
your patience it's been a crazy time
over here but all good all good uh on
this day though i really want to talk
about martin luther king jr for just a
moment you know everyone sort of uses
him for their own political purposes on
a day like today it's one of the sort of
most miserable uh days that you can be
online in a certain respect because it's
like uh is that really what he would
have believed and would he have wanted
someone like you to say that and
everything else so i was trying to find
a clip that i thought would just
illustrate something in a broad sense so
first i want to throw to this clip it's
about 50 seconds
if i lived in
china or even russia or any totalitarian
country
maybe i could understand
some of these illegal injunctions
maybe i could understand the denial of
certain basic first amendment privileges
because they haven't committed
themselves to that
over there
but somewhere i read
of the freedom of assembly
somewhere i read
of the freedom of speech
somewhere i read
of the freedom of press
somewhere i read
that the greatness of america is the
right to protest far right
[Applause]
man isn't that beautiful i don't even
have to add much commentary to that
it's like even back then
we had the tools we had the documents
to free ourselves and that's what we've
done consistently in america expanded
more freedom to more people and allowed
for freedom of speech and freedom of
assembly so that more and more people
could share in the american dream
that dr martin luther king jr was always
talking about so that his children
wouldn't be judged by the color of their
skin but by the content of their
character
and that's not how it is in totalitarian
regimes and it's like does it feel like
maybe we're giving that stuff away right
now are we possibly giving it away how
does our freedom of assembly feel right
now how does our freedom of speech
feel right now
that's for you to decide
so on this day i would say
maybe we've got all the tools we need
maybe we've got the documents we need
maybe we live in the country we're
supposed to live in but it's up to us to
strengthen those things it's up to us to
live up to those ideals and it's up to
us to fight for the things
most importantly equality the equality
that martin luther king wanted more than
anything else uh okay guys i thank you
for your time oh the sun is coming
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell